one of those campaigns began today in
north las vegas
some of the highest cases have been
reported in zip codes eight
nine zero three zero zero three one and
zero three two
as sally jaramillo reports those are the
areas needing more outreach
the martin luther king senior center is
located in an area of north las vegas
that has some of the highest covet 19
case numbers yet has the lowest
vaccination rates
in clark county north las vegas
officials want to change that
with pop-up clinics at locations like
these the residents of north las vegas
north las vegas city councilwoman pamela
goins-brown along with clark county
commissioner william mccurdy the second
we're here to encourage the community to
get vaccinated
goings-brown says since the pandemic
started they have been doing
outreach to help people and every penny
of keras money they received
has been to help people get tested
support struggling businesses
keep people in their homes and find work
we are actually
going to expand that outreach not just
in north las vegas but other
jurisdictions
first of all we had to start with our
marketing materials to get them
translated into multiple languages so
that everyone has access to that
information because they did not at
first
outreach will be done through social
media phone calls email
and media they will also partner with
community centers and churches
to plan more pop-up sites north las
vegas leaders say the sooner we get
vaccinated the faster we can get our
community and economy
back on track reporting sally jaramillo
8 news now